There's no sound in space.
Sound waves exist as variations in a pressure medium.
Such as air to bounce off.
And since there's no gas or anything else to bounce off in outer space,
epic space battles with almost certainly be mute.
However, you would be able to hear something hit the hull
because the collision against the hull would vibrate
the oxygen within the ship and bounce around it till it reached your ears.
Asteroid fields are not nearly as big a risk as you think.
The possibility of successfully navigating an asteroid field is
approximately 3,720 to 1!
Not in our universe anyway.
Asteroids are typically hundreds of miles apart.
So, your tiny space craft has plenty of breathing room.
Nasa has already sent no less than 8 unmanned spacecrafts
straight through the Mars Jupiter asteroid belt without incident.
Sorry, C3PO, but the chance of running into an asteroid is
estimated to be about one in a billion.
Never tell me the odds.
You can't turn and inertia on and off whenever you feel like it.
If the crew is thrown around the ship when a torpedo
hits the hull
they should reel back when accelerating really fast, even in space
objects have mass and if there's mass there's inertia
so this is perhaps the most accurate depiction of space travel inertia
ever to be captured in science fiction
your body will not explode if exposed to the vacuum of space
your skin and circulatory system are designed to keep most of your fluids and
gas inside your body
so they would not actually be exposed to the vacuum and boil
however your lungs would hyper-inflation and pop from the air being blown out
so quick
You would not instantly freeze in space
Sure, space is very cold but there's also nothing around to absorb
your natural body heat.
So there is no thermal conduction. You wouldn't survive more than 15 seconds in
space before losing consciousness
but she might actually survive this.
You can cry in space and the tears would not fall off or float away
they would stick emblem on to your face like jello
gravity on other planets moons and asteroids
is not the same as on earth most objects in the universe have a much weaker or
much stronger gravitational pull
so you'd either be bouncing off the surface with every step
or crossed into the ground if there's an explosion in space
it's not a glorious and fantastic fireball Fire can't sustain itself in
space due to the lack of oxygen.
Explosions instead have an initial bright flash and a resulting spherical
fireball that flight apart so quickly
you can even see it, kinda like a firecracker.